demain quoi qu'il se passe il n'y aura
pas d'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites
mais maintenant dans une crise
démocratique et quand la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale change les règles
au fur et à mesure de la partie pour en
influencer le résultat il y a quelques
jours alors
des oppositions d'ailleurs ni pour faire
plaisir à la majorité en l'occurrence on
est dans le respect strict des règles
constitutionnelles sur ces amendements
de rétablissement de l'article 1 je suis
très clair ils seront déclarés
irrecevables par moi-même dans la
journée aujourd'hui et je suis en train
d'examiner l'ensemble des autres
amendements puisqu'il y aura évidemment
d'autres irrecevabilités qui seront
prononcées
inadmissibles de l'exécutif sur le
législatif les pompiers Pyroman feraient
bien attention de ne pas se brûler les
doigts conséquence les insoumis veulent
déposer une motion de censure contre le
gouvernement il y a le brun Pivet a
préféré le rôle de portefeuille à celui
de garantes des intuition c'est comme ça
que vous considérez aujourd'hui la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale oui
parce que je pense que d'ailleurs elle a
hésité elle a résisté à la pression et
puis à un moment donné elle a cédé et au
moment où elle a cédé elle a tous cédé
très clairement elle a failli puisque
elle a décidé d'obéir aux ordres qui
étaient faits par le président et le
gouvernement et c'est contraire à ce que
doit faire une présidente de l'Assemblée
elle fait rentrer dans l'hémicycle la
voix du président alors même que en tant
que président de l'Assemblée elle
devrait être garante des institutions et
donc oui je lui en veux
une première génération
se menir vieux de 7000 en été pas seul
il y en avait une quarantaine tous
répertoriés par les autorités
aujourd'hui détruit pour laisser place à
un magasin de bricolage on a été reçu
très très bien
j'ai été entendue
soutenu et
[Musique]
je pense que qu'elle va nous aider
réellement le site était bien référencé
par la drague la Direction Régionale des
Affaires Culturelles il aurait donc dû
être protégé pourtant la mairie a
accordé un permis de construire en août
2022 Astérix chez Monsieur Bricolage ça
c'est notre proposition avec les
graphistes de c'est à vous le maire de
Carnac plaid une erreur dans le plan
local d'urbanisme et évoque une
incompréhension avec la drague contactez
la direction du magasin dit regretté
sincèrement cette situation mais le mal
est fait le ciel d'Ottawa au Canada est
teinté de Orange vous le voyez et baigné
dans un épais brouillard c'est le
résultat des incendies gigantesques qui
ravage la forêt au Québec et puis en
Ukraine des dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont déjà été évacués dans le
sud du pays après la destruction du
barrage hydro
hydroalcool du barrage hydraulique
pardon poussé par les vents et fumées
ont traversé des centaines de kilomètres
et envahit le ciel de certaines grandes
villes américaines comme New York
ça vient des incendies qui ravages le
Canada hydro hydroélectrique voilà on va
y arriver c'est simple c'est assez
compliqué de vous dire que demain ça ira
mieux nous avons environ 78 incendies en
ce moment dans le témiska Mingue Abitibi
nous arrivons à combattre 12
ce qui nous a marqué nous aujourd'hui
bien c'est cette forte odeur d'essence
dans toute la ville selon les autorités
près de 150 tonnes d'essence ont été
déversées dans le Nieppe et ses environs
depuis l'explosion hier ce qui fait
redouter une catastrophe écologique et
si rosé Jack avait eu une fin heureuse à
l'issue de leur voyage sur le Titanic
leur famille aurait pu ressembler à ça
une photo de Jérémy pommeroy générée par
l'intelligence artificielle l'artiste
s'est également amusé à imaginer les
enfants qu'aurai pu avoir l'ex couple
star d'Hollywood Jennifer Aniston et
Brad Pitt oui il y aura un contrôle
technique sur les deux roues le Conseil
d'État demande le gouvernement de
prendre sa décision juridique en arrêté
sous deux mois donc d'ici début août
mais ensuite la mise la mise en oeuvre
prendra un peu plus de temps sans doute
pas avant la fin de l'année ou encore
Selena Gomez et Justin Bieber il a même
créé la famille fictive de John
Fitzgerald Kennedy et Marilyn Monroe